hi I'm Greg street from league of
legends at Riot Games and I am doing
wired League of Legends support I bout
the red asked hey riot have been playing
the game since season three and never
really understood how you picked the
free champ rotation is it algorithm or
something else I mean this is the kind
of things a little bit of art and a
little bit of science we try to make
sure that there are enough champions
available that you can make a team comp
of all free to play champions there also
some that we'd like to have in the
rotation because they're particularly
good for particularly for new players
and we have others that we don't really
want in rotation because they're really
hard to learn or they're about to be you
know massively remade or things like
that candy cane asks when will Teemo get
deleted you know we've tried to delete
Teemo several times there's a quirk or
something in the code he just keeps
coming back can't keep a good diamond
down NaCl samurais that salt samurai
they'll be funny I see there's some
quality life changes come to a ram but
why is the Oracle extract still a thing
it ruins any trap invisible stealth
champs I think what he's getting at is
it really runs Teemo which I think was
partially honestly the origin of the
item you know a ram wasn't designed to
have champ to the ton of invisibility
around all the time
I think aside from Shaco and Teemo it
shouldn't affect that many champions
that much the SKA asks hey riot Arian
was released four years ago after you
started why is it taking so long to
release another permanent game that's a
great question overall we've used
summoners rift as kind of the core
League of Legends experience we're not
against offering other maps but we want
to make sure that that they're good ones
and they really add something to the
game the howling abyss the Aran map is
really popular among players I think
that one's a keeper it obviously has a
large audience and the real answer is we
could come up with a really good mode
that we felt good about and players
enjoyed then we're fine having another
permanent game-mode but it's not a goal
of ours to go ahead and add a ton of
different maps to League if that makes
sense
magic turtle says I'm new to League of
Legends and I need a good beginner
champion comment please there's a lot of
good beginner champions I think the best
thing to do is just pick a champion that
you're excited about
even though League has 140 septic
champions when you're just learning the
game you probably want to pick one or
two and play a lot of games in that
character until you really kind of
understand the basics their popular good
champions I would say are like Miss
Fortune Zed Master Yi Garen is a common
one I would stay away from say Calista
Azir a really
so they play really differently from
kind of the the standard League champion
it's never too late to pick it up many
different phenomena that's a great name
says why did you all decide it was good
idea to make the death timer so long and
one for all over time the kind of
classic summoners rift experience has
gotten longer and longer and when the
average game time gets to be in the 40
minutes or so that feels a little long
to a lot of players we don't want to
arbitrarily just say look League of
Legends should be a 20-minute game and
that's it but we do want to make sure
that the game doesn't drag on and on or
it's kind of hard to fit in your
lifestyle it's not that one for all is
necessarily always tied to long death
timers but that was an experiment we're
trying to see if we could make the games
end a little faster I tried to pronounce
this thing by half Nero iTunes wise the
entire team punished in rank for someone
ragequitting we see all these unneeded
gameplay changes each week that the rank
system set stagnant for so long we
deserve updates this season we are
changing rank we were changing it for
next season because touching ranked is
kind of one of the scarier things we
could do for League of Legends
it's an easy way for us to screw up the
game if we're not careful these changes
like any change to rank tend to be a
little controversial so we're giving
players plenty of time to kind of react
to what we want to do and make sure that
when we finally do launch the new
version of rank that it's something that
you guys are excited about as far as why
everyone is punished for someone
ragequitting we don't ever want to set
the team up in a situation where you
guys are kind of voting and saying hey
we're gonna make one player the
sacrifice and you quit so that we can
all don't get punished as much but we
can like end the game sooner or
something like that and as a tip it's
probably not going really badly at first
blood you don't need to give up that
quickly
milk's ki asks can you guys please
please please put trading in all random
earth we're talking about it you know we
had trading in a ram which is all random
and we just kind of wanted to try to see
if we could improve the earth experience
by having the champion selection be
random as well if that seems like a
popular change and the whole kind of
history of riot turning earth on and off
is pretty complex and probably would
take longer to explain that I should go
to right now but short term is if it
seems like a good change and it's
something players really like that we
could certainly consider it they did to
that Richie says please bring back old
or all random earth is so boring because
you'll only play with popular champions
you can't try new champions and that's
why I'll random earth with a little bit
we have a weird history with earth earth
tends to make league players quit
playing league of legends which sounds
really weird but we see this huge
hangover effect whenever we turn on
earth players play it a lot and then
they stop playing league and suppose
they'll even come back to league so
we're faced with this really weird
situation of this is nothing players
really love that makes them actually
quit the game so we have to decide as a
player focused company do we want to be
so player focused that we kind of put
ourselves out of business you know
supporting earth or not
Romo says I downloaded league of legends
and I am so confused the game won't see
the battle with another player but I
still do not know how to control it
Romo we have just updated the tutorial
experience for League of Legends the one
we had has been in the game forever
and it was not doing a great job at
teaching new players how to play the
game the best way to learn League of
Legends is to find a friend who plays
League of Legends and have them teach
you the game that's still the best way
to day but we realized that we were kind
of shirking our responsibility by not
offering a way that you could try to
pick it up yourself I think we tried it
again the game will do a little bit of a
better job of kind of explaining here's
why you are here's where you want to be
as a league player and kind of help you
take the steps to get there and mcintyre
says hey guys I don't know where to ask
this formally but is there a chance you
could introduce a help Ward Earp a it's
actually a really cool idea I'm not sure
if we've talked about that before if
it's somewhere on the backlog but it
seems like a useful thing they've been
trying to make our ping system a little
more powerful so that it people can use
that to kind of communicate with your
teammates because it's faster and having
to type something out guhong asked my
boyfriend has been crying because he
found a new patch to be reached today
with pike in it i said that's not the
case he insisted that usually Riot
releases champions a week after his
first on the TV I mean generally that's
how it works out we put a public beta
test up and if it you know all goes well
we don't need to make major changes then
we'll release the champion but that's
not a hard and fast rule it's more about
how we want to release the champion
overall and with pike as you probably
realize by now there's a huge event that
goes along with him you know it's very
Bilgewater themed there's the a ram map
turned back on and some new skins and
that sort of thing so we wanted to make
sure we could drop all of that at the
same time Aaron says so how long until
League of Legends battle royale game
mode is announced we had a really hard
time even getting hexakill to work or we
have six champions at each side I'm not
sure we could get a hundred or more
champions into the game on the other
hand there are some really cool things
that Battle Royale does that I'd love to
be able to capture for example the
expectation that you probably won't win
you'll probably lose so you're just kind
of in there to have fun that's a really
nice element whereas in league
statistically if our matchmaking is
working well you're gonna lose about
half of your games I'd love if there is
a game mode in league like that where
you felt like you were kind of in there
to do crazy things and see how far you
could get versus like crush the enemy
team but whatever form that takes
probably can't be a battle royale Mike
Wow how'd you get that name hello is the
support man is it possible to get an
in-game stat for damage dealt by ZZ rot
and banner of command that's a great
question and we actually have some plans
to improve the stats we offer though the
ones we do now have been you know that
system hasn't been touched in ages and
something you know it's not you're not
gonna see in the next few patches but
long term we would love to offer a lot
more stats particularly so players who
aren't so focused on you know dealing
damage of getting kills will also have
some stats they can be excited about or
or try to improve over time then so
they'll ask hey guys one quick question
do you lose more LP when you surrender
instead of letting the enemy destroy
your Nexus I think the what he's trying
to get at is if I'm gonna lose should I
quickly surrender to lose fewer LP and
the answer is the game doesn't really
care how you lose it just gives you you
know you lose LP when you lose so you
shouldn't worry about trying to game it
if you're gonna lose elegantly because
you surrender or if you got to go down
fighting to the end it's it's kind of
all the same to the game Jubal says
Lowell to when honestly probably never
liked League of Legends is an ongoing
game it's something that we support it's
something that evolves over time I think
the only reason to launch a League of
Legends two would be some kind of
cynical marketing campaign or you're
like trying to get players you know
excited about the game again but it
shouldn't require that we should be able
to get players excited about the game
because League of Legends is a good game
not because we need to kind of rebrand
it and relaunch it and I would hesitate
to ever like take away players
accomplishments and say hey just start
over again and this probably sounds like
I am scrubbing on a bunch of other games
out there which not all my intention I'm
just saying for League of Legends it's
about League of Legends not about the
you know the sequels that we make every
year yes I think that wraps it up we've
got a lot of great stuff planned this
year for League of Legends hopefully
some cool surprises coming up at the end
of the season too so thanks a lot